gracias gracias
me sorprende hoy en día la capacidad que
los seres humanos tenemos para responder
a algunas cosas
claro ejemplo es tu teléfono seguramente
suena y lo respondes cuánto tiempo
tardaremos 5 segundos 10 segundos me
sorprende también hoy en día aunque no
es muy común el timbre de las casas y
que de repente también tengamos la
capacidad de responder
me hago estas preguntas porque entonces
por qué no respondemos de manera
inmediata a un estímulo sexual
seguramente cuando uno piensa en
estímulos sexuales y en esta capacidad
de respuesta yo me hago algunas
preguntas algunas es porque los
impedimentos ante las respuestas
sexuales acaso es culpable mi mamá
no sientas pórtate bien
esas cosas son del demonio
y entonces fíjate cómo te vamos
inhibiendo en una capacidad de respuesta
cuando se nos dio de manera natural
y quiero imaginar que en ese proceso no
tenemos un proceso formativo en
educación sexual levante la mano quien
tuvo la materia de sexualidad humana
quiero ver muy bien espero que haya sido
materia no curso no taller o seminario
mucho menos optativa imagínate y la
sexualidad optativa me hace recordar a
la señora que le decían oye que te gusta
más hacer el amor o la navidad
y por supuesto que la navidad llega más
seguido
no podemos pensar que la sexualidad sea
una materia optativa
entonces yo quiero de verdad envidiar a
los que levantaron la mano te imaginas
vamos a imaginar todos ese escenario
mamá así no voy a hacer
clase para mañana
de que hijo de sexualidad
y me dejaron material didáctico mamá
que te dejaron que una música
si entendieron
y para que no se pero dijo que ahí vamos
a desarrollar algunas habilidades
te imaginas yo quiero visualizar la
evaluación para dish y mono
es más yo pensando en sexualidad
hasta extraordinario me gustaría ir
primer parcial de eso no va contigo para
más o menos
examen final o proyecto mínimo orgasmo
te imaginas entonces el título de
suficiencia
si te andan pidiendo un multi orgasmo
entonces nos damos cuenta que el tema de
la sexualidad no es un tema que nos
hayamos formado
y la realidad creo que es un tema
pendiente en el que deberíamos de
empezar a trabajar y lo voy a decir por
qué
hay estudios longitudinales en algunos
países en donde a tus 10 87
años de edad empezaron a desarrollar
algunas habilidades algunos
conocimientos y algunas actitudes ante
la sexualidad 20-25 años después fueron
a buscar esas personas que habían
educado sexualmente sorpresa
la primera fue la visión oye a lo largo
de tu vida has tenido alguna infección
de transmisión sexual y la respuesta fue
que es eso habla muy bien palomita
oye a lo largo de tu vida tuviste algún
embarazo no planeado por supuesto que no
hoy podrías decirnos la edad en la que
se presentó tu primera actividad vital
sexual algunos dijeron en esas ando
otras dioses apenas otras bueno pues
como cualquiera pues por ahí de los 1817
la siguiente pregunta me encantó nos
podrías enlistar el número de parejas
sexuales que has tenido a lo largo de tu
vida no ven ahí empezó lo interesante y
cuando hablo del proceso formativo
fíjense qué bonito aquí voy a hacer un
paréntesis señoras señores por qué no
educar y no formar en la naturalidad de
la sexualidad imagínate los que tengamos
hijos que puedas decirle a tus hijos de
hombre y yo cincuenta parejas no
empieces no específicas sexuales pero
por lo menos 50 parejas para que para
tener yo ese referente
bueno ojalá tu hija o tu hijo no tenían
mamá de verdad 50 parejas
de verdad que si no digo de verdad entre
los 50 mi papá fue el mejor
como estarían nosotros
pero entonces cuando hablamos justamente
del número de parejas sexuales
encontramos que estos chavitos que
habían sido educados con lanús ita y que
habían sido educados en la sexualidad
tenían menor número de parejas sexuales
que cualquier otra persona pero el
último elemento y el más importante
hablaron de satisfacción sexual y
sorpresa 10 todos
y porque 10 todos porque les dieron tres
elementos conocimientos sobre sexualidad
yo siempre le dije a mi maestra de
inglés con usted que voy a aprender a
hablar a escribir a entender a platicar
o de qué se trata me dijo no no sé
en la sexualidad si tendremos que ser
muy precisos porque la información está
es algo que no significa avance es más
yo he visto cajetillas de cigarros que
traen unas promociones bien interesantes
y todas estas dicen también el de la
ratita por familia
entonces fíjate como la información no
necesita innecesariamente modificar
conductas
que modifica conductas y las actitudes
qué significa que tendríamos que
transformar y a veces hasta pelear con
el entorno familiar
yo recuerdo alguna ocasión veía yo a mi
mamá en la cocina y pegaba un pepino
terminando el pepino le corta las puntas
y detalla
e inexperto y eso más que ya sabes frase
célebre para que no sea nadie
y yo me pongo a pensar cuántos fenómenos
de esa naturaleza
imaginar también en la sexualidad los
traemos al mundo real
es decir con cuánto tabú con cuánto mito
caminamos alrededor de la sexualidad
pero afortunadamente tuvo un día la
oportunidad de salir de casa encontré
dos cosas fundamentales primero que mi
mamá no hacía la mejor sopa del mundo
hasta que comían otra casa
para aquellos que están pensando en el
primer amor chequen
el primer amor para lo único que te
sirve es para que sea referente para los
que viene
y lo segundo puede lograr mi
independencia de pensamiento compré un
pepino fui a la cocina y pele el pepino
y dije mi madre pero cuando dije mi
madre sentí su sombra atrás
yo dije no me arriesgo
y que detalló
yo diga bueno entonces en qué momento
voy a desprender de todo esto en qué
momento voy a brincar la capacidad de
desprenderme de mi proceso social que
fue el que me educó sexualmente
y después entiendo y empiezo a
comprender que la sexualidad tiene marco
de referencia tiene marco de evaluación
caray apenas fui al súper no voy a decir
marcas encanto la chava ya sabes no
y voltea así todo inspirada
encontró lo que buscaba y le digo no
dice aunque
claro yo le dije oiga y pues como para
que pregunta no
es que mi gerente me dijo pues ya le
dije y ahora no no me dijo el siguiente
proceso fíjate entonces como la
asexualidad tiene eso
no sería padre y señor id
es más hoy los invito a que lleguen que
no trae pareja por supuesto levante la
mano quien otra pareja
ya le hicimos
que llegue hoy en la noche a su casa y
así sutil le diga que cree es amor en tu
ausencia descubrí una nueva zona erógena
pues sí aquí estoy
y yo que no tengo es que el doctor me
dijo que necesitaba yo vida sexual
intensa y entonces yo pero es que me
dijo que nada de remedios caseros
fíjate entonces como la sexualidad
debería tener esa capacidad de encontró
lo que buscaba
pero allí como voy a pedir que podamos
evaluar el nivel de un orgasmo si no soy
capaz de decirle lavarte los dientes
como le voy a decir ahí
en lugar de ay
entonces hasta parece me encantó una
definición de alguien un día maravillosa
ser el amor es como estacionar un
trailer
grandote el monstruo uno arriba uno
abajo pero uno diciéndole viene viene
para acá para acá izquierda derecha de
lennon o salsas ataditos atendido bien
viene mejor así todo todo todo
entonces durante cuando hablamos de
comunicación me parece que es uno de los
obstáculos más grandes que tenemos los
seres humanos
como voy a llegar entonces a mi mundo de
la sexualidad donde hago otro paréntesis
chicas pongan atención donde más del 80%
de las mujeres en este país donde
tuvieron su primera relación coital no
lo decidieron
cuando digo no lo decidieron es porque
alguien las engaño las obligó les hizo
manita de puerco o cualquier situación
frases las que ustedes me digan
cuál te gusta la más simple nunca te voy
a abandonar
siempre estaré a tu lado
y la del mexicano no te va a doler
pero hago segundo paréntesis 98% de las
niñas que quedan embarazadas el marido
en la inmediatez o en la pareja las va a
abandonar
entonces fíjate como vivimos de repente
una sexualidad en fantasía una
sexualidad que suponemos nos va a llevar
al buen vivir hoy en la mañana la última
noticia más fresca en menos de cinco
años muchos de los países invertirán en
su producto interno bruto por recuperar
la salud mental de las personas y cuando
digo la salud mental está implícita la
salud de la sexualidad porque pues
porque no nos dieron esa materia ese
taller digo lo bueno que algunos sí
tuvieron la materia salvarán a la
humanidad pero me parece que es el
momento de saber por dónde vamos
cuando hablo de respuesta sexual humana
fíjense qué fácil es señores levanten la
mano a quien le gusta el cine el cine
creen que el cine vaya a quebrar esta
semana un hombre
lo que no nos han dicho y no nos los van
a decir es el exitazo del cine gracias a
qué
estando ahí mira desde que llegas
ya llegué
desde que entras pantalla gigante que
está más grande que tu casa
desde que te sientas un confort que
dices virgen santa si me duermo
los sonidos no aquí hoy es rápido y
furioso
hasta volteas ella tenemos hoy el cine
3d
la de frente no salpica el total
padrísimo y hoy espero que las x nos no
las hagan
3b no
y cuando empiezas a saborear las
palomitas digo yo por lo menos no si
usted esto no empieza la película y a
media paloma de a bailo
fíjate entonces tus cinco sentidos y
entro en materia de respuesta sexual
humana tus cinco sentidos son los que
van a determinar justamente esto
la respuesta sexual humana por proceso
educativo lo voy a explicar es decir por
fases ya digo proceso educativo y hace
que no estás con tu pareja y así pase
una ya estás excitada
fase 2 cómo va la meseta fase 3 me
avisas lo del orgasmo no y fase 4
resolución así se nos enseñaba la
sexualidad y por qué traigo a población
el cine porque hoy nos hemos dado cuenta
que la fase 0 de la respuesta sexual
humana está determinada por algo que se
llama estímulo sexual efectivo
lo traduzco lo que te gusta de pánfilo
punto y no andes ahí con la amiga como
lo ves
como exista guapo no
por supuesto que no es el mismo estímulo
sexual efectivo para ti para ello cuando
el estímulo sexual efectivo está
presente quiere decir que tus cinco
sentidos se alinean
y ahí entra la definición de me gustas
te gustó y nos damos gusto
pero te puedo amar pero si el olor es
suficientemente importante así lo es
todo
te puedo adorar pero si tus manos son
más allá de una lija
y te puedo encantar en todos los
sentidos pero a lo mejor visualmente te
adoro me encanta cómo estás y de repente
la pareja apaga la luz
pon
así con el mismo que apagase el switch
a pasar la pared es que no te gusto
si me gustabas pero cuando te veía
entonces vi a t ahí pudieron encontrar
no hace más de 20 25 años y mira que la
humanidad tiene mucho más que eso que
las disfunciones sexuales estaban
asociadas a la inadecuada identificación
del estímulo sexual efectivo así de
fácil
señores si el estímulo sexual efectivo
es adecuado voy a llegar a un proceso de
excitación lo más visible lubricación en
la mujer erección en el hombre
si logro esto voy a llegar a una meseta
señores para que aprendamos todos en la
fase de meseta y algo que se llama
plataforma orgásmica se sucede al
interior de la vagina en la mujer y es
lo voy a explicar fácil es como un aro
donde se concentra más sangre y
determina la posibilidad de que lo que
entre no cause dolor y no pero ahí
bajamos a la penetración inmediata
porque así nos enseñaron rápido ándale
que se te va se acaba y después vamos a
llegar entonces al orgasmo sensación
subjetiva de placer pero el que lo
trabaja es el que lo logra llegar a un
período refractario y finalmente llegar
a una capacidad de iniciar una nueva
relación fíjate qué interesante es esto
en este período refractario y en esta
resolución es donde los seres humanos
tenemos determinar dos cosas una saber
que la mujer tiene todo un tablero como
avión así lo voy a explicar puntos por
todos lados si se lo imaginan así
tenemos que lograr la excitación en la
mujer
si se miraron el tablero del avión se
imaginaron lo complejo que es excitar
una mujer
bueno voy a explicar el tablero del
hombre
han visto un vocho
quiero concluir diciéndoles y esta
película es maravillosa se acordarán de
la película nueve semanas y media para
los que no la vieron un clásico de los
80s dónde nos enseñaron y no a través de
calígula sino de ella donde la
gastrobares sólo un ejemplo
poner miel
cerezas fresas crema chantilly no se
vuelve y excitante un fenómeno de esa
naturaleza pero por favor no me vayan a
salir a ir poniéndole chicharrón en
chile verde
la sexualidad tiene un compromiso y ese
compromiso se asume desde el principio y
de manera individual pásenla bien
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]